where did you plant flowers I used to
work at a place called Acacia Park
Cemetery in Birmingham Michigan and uh
and and I was the I was the I planted
the flower beds and it was really really
fun I used to get up at five o'clock in
the morning and go hang out with the
Chipmunks and the rabbits and make sure
I was pruning all the flowers and and
having a good time it was I felt like
Snow White you know what I mean I love
that if you're working in the face of
mortality right does it make you think
about yeah it does it gives it gives me
some perspective that you want to
because when you're doing something like
that you kind of think to yourself so
what what what did these people did
these people get the dreams that they
wanted in their lives did they achieve
the things they wanted in their lives
and it's it makes me think of things
like when I when I uh when I first met L
we were having a conversation
yes we were having a conversation about
what was going to happen after Key and
Peele and I remember her uh she asked me
a question I had never heard before in
my life which was if you were not gonna
if there were stories that you didn't
make up if there were stories that you
made up about yourself about why you
couldn't do something
if those stories weren't there what
would you do why would you what would
what would I want to accomplish if I was
not getting in my own way I know what
would you accomplish if you if you
weren't telling yourself stories about
why you couldn't do something what could
you accomplish I mean that moves me so
much look I see these two women up there
they this is what just happened they
looked at each other they go
thank you so much are you guys
accomplished you guys are accomplishing
something in your lives right now look
at that I feel like they started a
business together may I ask why but
first what your names are
I'm Alexa Savannah why did you guys just
look at each other and do the I know nod
um I have a severe fear of flying so it
was tough it was so tough flying here
because I was like holding her hand
grasping it for dear life so when you
said that I was like oh my gosh I would
love to travel I want to go to Europe I
want to go to California even see
and I was like I looked at her and I was
like Savannah oh my gosh I could I could
fly to Europe if I got out of my own
head and Alexa what what how did where
did you fly from to get here Atlanta
from Atlanta yes and you did it I did it
it was rough but I did it
thank you
if if you will get on the flight I want
to get you two tickets to Europe but you
gotta go can you do it I can do it
look at you
[Applause]
okay speaking of like I can do anything
amazing imaginative World Super Mario
Brothers I can't remember a time of life
without it yeah no I know
I know
it is it is part it is really part of
the fabric of this Society it really is
that game and I I go way back way back
to the OG to the dkog I was a Donkey
Kong guy
I love Donkey Kong which is our you know
that original debut of Mario and I love
how imaginative the game is because I
mean why why does a mushroom make you
grow bigger why does a hidden thing make
coins come out because and who and who
cares you know what I mean oh okay Lewis
Lewis Carroll from Alice in Wonderland
so I love that Super Mario Brothers is
something that transcends everything
everything
and Global right yeah intergenerational
intergenerational okay there's also
schmickedoon
um and your character does not like
singing and is it true like that you
sang impromptu I think this is another L
moment you told me once when I was with
you and Al and I think we were actually
on a phone call on speaker at this point
you were singing Somewhere you weren't
supposed to sing doors opened L what
happened well the the big thing was that
I sang well I sang to my wife at our
wedding and uh and and during that time
L was saying to me you you enjoy singing
so much
um maybe you should sing more and then
after she said that I was like yeah
you're right and she's been she was so
encouraging in in this in this endeavor
of me singing more and now the last you
projects I've done I'm singing in them I
saying in the prom
you yeah exactly I sing I sing to Meryl
Streep I mean and this is because my
wife said why don't you sing a little
bit more you know I mean
this doesn't accomplish drop the
narrative and go forward with your
dreams you two could be singing with
Meryl Streep
[Applause]
because it made me think about about uh
Alex and Savannah it made me think about
the facts so it's it's those so when
you're in Europe think about my wife
because she was the one that told me
this
as you said all good doors like lead to
Al and her Opening match yeah she opened
yeah it's like I'm the key and she and
she she knows where the doors are so you
just have to have the courage to put the
key in the door it's always wonderful
you have someone in your life who can
show you where the doors are and I'm
very very fortunate in that regard you
know so
[Applause]
laughs
all right I have a new mantra for my
love life thank you okay hon you need to
find someone who helps you open the
doors you need to find someone who helps
you open the doors yes yes thank you
you're welcome you're welcome I want
that for you
that means so much to me
is it true that singing at your wedding
wasn't the only time you sang though
didn't you sing back in the day for
something oh I did yes I used to do
singing telegrams and I played I used to
play I used to wear this like to bring
It full circle I used to wear this like
Grim Reaper costume and go into like
Office Buildings for people's 40th
birthdays and I'd walk in in this big
lumbering you know Grim Reaper costume
and
um and uh and I also played like a
caveman I did like a caveman and I wore
tails and a white tuxedo and played this
guy named Mr Wonderful and it was this
company that was around for a long time
and that was one of my that was
something I did in my career
people's birthdays and for people's
birthdays yes isn't it your birthday
today is
[Music]
thank you